hello everyone once again
welcome to today's
webinar
today we are going to have an amazing
talk by dr christopher m taylor
on the topic of
metagenomics and
microbial communities which is one of
the very much popular topic
of this era
we will be waiting for
four to five minutes more so that more
people can join in
and soon we will be beginning with
today's session so once again thank you
everyone for
tuning in today
so
stick around tight
grab your seats and we will begin with
today's very exciting session
very shortly
all right so hello everybody
good morning
to the people who are joining
from the other part of the world and
good evening good afternoon to the
people who are located in the other
parts
i welcome you all to today's
psionics student club webinar
psiomix brings you
expert webinars every
month and in this sort of webinars we
talked about some of the most popular
topics
in today's world
be it in the domain of life sciences
bioinformatics
omics
and any other field
we are excited to talk about and learn
from the experts about these
exciting new fields
so
it gives me immense pleasure to see all
of you today who have
joined us for this particular webinar so
without any further ado
let's begin with today's
psionic session
let me introduce myself to begin with my
name is subrajit varuva i'm the
scientific outreach coordinator at find
biotech and also the president of the
zionist student club
and miss ruth vivaja is the vice
president of our student club
psyomix
is more than a club it's a community
it's a huge family of more than 1000
students from different countries in the
world
with more than 20 experts and scientists
and researchers who share guide and
mentor us
and we also boost
a large 30 plus rich alumni network from
different universities who have been a
part of our community for
a long long time and now they are
contributing from the knowledge and the
expertise that they have gained from
different experiences different projects
different researchers they are now
applying it in their work in the
in the domain of bioinformatics that
gives us immense pleasure and immense
pride
psionics
is as i mentioned a huge community of
bioinformatics and data science
enthusiasts all across the world we have
people who are interested in various
applications of bioinformatics genomics
such as infectious diseases
microbes and microbiome neuroscience
plant science precision oncology
and even the most recent fields of
omics and bioinformatics namely
astrobiology and space omics
the goal of psionics club is to clarify
the concepts of bioinformatics
give each other insights on the tools of
bioinformatics and how to use them to
help each other
get started with their research projects
and also to gain experience on data
science skill sets
but how do we achieve this goal of ours
well
let me introduce you
to omix logic
omixlogic is a community with a goal
to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided
mentors and peer example projects so
that students can benefit the most
out of
their
learning experience
omixlogic also supports developing a
growing community such as the psionics
club with shared passion for data-driven
research and appreciation of citizen
science projects
and finally omixlogic enables students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology
in life and data sciences
in the month of january 2022
we are observing the metagenomics month
we have had
various webinars workshops and training
programs dedicated to the field of
metagenomics that ran across the month
of january
but what is metagenomics well as a as
you might be familiar with metagenomics
deals with the study of the microbial
world the microbes microbial communities
and their interactions
but
the study of microbes or as we call it
microbiology is not a recent field at
all
in fact it is one of the oldest fields
of science which began way back in the
1600s
when the first microscopic organism was
observed under the compound microscope
since then
various scientists students and
communities have largely contributed to
the rapid development
and understanding of this vast field of
science which today has taken the shape
and form of metagenomics
which goes hand in hand with
microbiology
as we have learned about it more and
developed a bigger and wider picture of
microbes we have understood that it's
not the individual microbes that play a
role or define the phenotypic
changes that we see instead they it is a
community or a colony of various
microbes residing together such as
bacteria fungi and viruses as you see
you can see on the slide
residing on your skin pores
these microbes not only reside together
but also communicate with one another
through various processes such as one of
them is called quorum sensing
as we have gained insights into these
sort of interactions and largely
developed an idea of how microbial
communities can
shape and affect our well-being
one of the major landmarks in the
development of these
experiences understanding and knowledge
was the american gut project
in this particular project
huge data samples was collected from
many participants all across the united
states of america
and these samples were analyzed to
understand the population of microbiome
residing in our gut
we found out
what are the factors that define these
colonies these communities and how they
in turn shape our lives
and as we developed and looked into more
insights we kind of understood that
these microbial communities not only
shape
the functionality of our gut or the
digestive system but also plays an
important role in deciding various other
physiological
and cognitive behaviors of organisms
such as this one
the study or analyze analysis of
the gut microbiome
led us to discover its relation with the
behavioral pattern of organism mice in
this case and that gave us insights into
the gut brain axis
this is a very interesting study that
was done where we identified how
the
community of microbes living inside the
organism's gut
can dictate the behavior of this
organism
and it gives me immense pleasure to
announce to all of you that today for
this webinar we have one of the authors
of this exciting research paper with us
as our guest
speaker
so without any further ado let me
introduce
to all of you dr christopher m taylor
associate professor of the department of
microbiology immunology and parasitology
louisiana state university health
sciences center
as the guest speaker for today's
webinar of psyomix
let me introduce our speaker for today's
session so dr taylor joined lsu hsc new
orleans in december 2012 as an associate
professor in the department of
microbiology immunology and parasitology
he is a founding member of the microbial
genomics resource group and has built an
informatics laboratory at the school of
medicine focused on microbial community
sequencing analysis and visualization
he was appointed in july 2016 as the
director of the bioinformatics
biostatistics and computational biology
core of the louisiana biomedical
research network lvrn and was awarded
tenure from lsu hsc new orleans in 2017.
dr taylor co-organizes an annual
conference on bioinformatics and
computational biology for lbrn and his
research laboratory maintains several
terabytes of sequence data and designs
innovative software systems for
visualization and analysis of high
throughput sequencing experiments he
also serves as the contact pi for a
recently awarded nsf grant that was
utilized to acquire and establish a high
performance computing cluster called
fish for computational biology and
bioinformatics research at lsu hsc new
orleans dr taylor's research interests
currently focuses on dynamic changes in
the vaginal microbiota associated with
various stis including pv clematia and
hiv
so without wasting any further time i
would like to transfer this virtual
podium to today's guest speaker dr
christopher m taylor dr taylor the stage
is all yours and welcome to psionics how
you are doing
thank you um
i'm gonna see if i can get my screen
share
going
yep we can see your screen well
is it in
presentation mode yeah all right i'm
good to go
so um
thanks for uh
the uh invitation to speak and uh the
introduction um as
as was said my name is christopher
taylor and i'm an associate professor at
the louisiana state
uh health sciences center in new orleans
and school of medicine
and my background is actually in
computer science
and i got involved in working with
genomics in the early 2000s soon after
the human genome was sequenced and
so i come at this
this field from a computational
perspective
so i like to kind of think about
computational biology as bridging the
gap between
the fields of computing and biology and
and bioinformatics in particular
requires
the application of computing technology
and programming to solve biological
problems and
in my lab in particular we often have
people who come from either side
from either of these fields
and
they bring unique perspectives depending
upon what their background is
so my major focus of the work that i do
is the human microbiome we also study a
lot of environmental samples and we look
at
animal models but most of my work
in my research tries to attack problems
that are
uh associated with human health and
disease because we are in the school of
medicine at louisiana state university
and as as was said the human body is
covered in bacteria you have bacteria
that lives on the surface of your skin
in your nose and your mouth your ear
your lungs your stomach
your intestines and reproductive tract
and those communities of bacteria can be
significant factors in health and
disease and indeed some diseases
are actually defined as
as a change in those microbial
communities
and the nih has funded uh since i think
2012 a uh
an initiative to characterize
the bacteria that live in and upon the
body called the human microbiome project
and that has had
several iterations
since it was initiated
so in terms of how we refer to
the terminology
when we say microbiota that refers to an
ecological community of organisms some
of them are commensal and some of them
are symbiotic and others pathogenic
this definition came out of the human
microbiome project working group
and technically microbiota includes not
only bacteria but also other
microbiological organisms such as
archaea protists fungi and viruses
however
often when people use the term
microbiota they implicitly mean just the
bacteria because that is
one of the more often studied
areas
and then if we say microbiome then
definitionally that technically refers
to the collective genomes of all the
microorganisms
that make up a given environmental niche
as opposed to microbiota which is
supposed to just refer to the organisms
themselves but often these terms are
used fairly interchangeably and i use
them interchangeably myself
even though that definitionally they
have different connotations
then there's also this a more
interesting idea of a holobiont which
refers to the host organism plus all of
the symbiotic microbes that live in and
upon it
and
that sort of way of looking at things
leads to a
recasting of the traditional theory of
evolution called the whole genome theory
of evolution
which
views not only the host organisms
as evolving over time but also the
community of microbes
that live in and upon those host
organisms
have also evolved together over time
then there's this term dysbiosis which
you've probably heard and it's really
used as a catch-all term
for some form of microbial imbalance
that occurs in one of the sites on the
body
normally the healthy community that is
normal at a given location it becomes
somehow deranged
and the species that normally make up
that community
decrease in abundance and allow for
opportunistic species to grow
most commonly dysbiosis is discussed in
terms of the gastrointestinal tract
which is gut dysbiosis
but that concept can actually affect any
of the common sites of microbial
colonization in particular i look a lot
at vaginal dysbiosis
the
change in this community of organisms or
this dysbiosis it can lead to or it can
be the result of a disease
and possible therapies for dysbiotic
states
are antibiotics which will kill for a
variety of bacteria
probiotics whereby you're trying to add
back
so-called good bacteria
or even a more extreme treatment fmt
which stands for fecal microbiota
transfer
and that's actually a technique that's
been used fairly successfully to treat
uh recurrent
antibiotic resistant clostridium
difficile
infection
so in terms of genomics technology dna
sequencing is the major tool that we use
and it's the process of determining the
identity and the order of the
nucleotides in a given piece of genetic
material whether that's dna or it's cdna
from an rna
molecule
and
the term genomics is the study of the
complete genome of a selected organism
and that includes all the dna sequences
and all of the genes of that organism in
question
so then when you get
to the term metagenomics it actually
adds in not only the host organism but
as was said studying the genetic
material from all the organisms
and with all the recent advances that
have occurred in dna sequencing
technologies they brought about a
revolution in genomics over the past
decade
and so the best way
of visualizing this is a graph that the
nhgri the national human genome research
institute maintains
and this graph shows from the year 2000
the cost
of
sequencing basically so this is cost per
megabase of sequence
and so um if you look at this
way back in 2000 the sequencing was
done via a technique called sanger
sequencing that was really the the
primary method for doing dna sequencing
and that technology had been around
since the late 70s and early 80s so it
had dominated the field of dna
sequencing for over 20 years
and you can see that it was uh fairly
expensive to sequence megabase of dna um
you know this is ten thousand dollars up
here at the very top
of the screen
and that's what it cost back in 2000
see if i can hide some of these bars
floating meeting controls okay
and so as time went on uh from 2000 to
about 2007
the reduction in cost of dna sequencing
was roughly following what's called
moore's law which is a an observation
not so much a law but an observation
in computing
that in the 80s and 90s and 2000s
the cost of computing was decreasing and
roughly being cut in half
about every 18 months well
cost of dna sequencing was also being
cut in half about every 18 months and
was following this white line
but suddenly
in about 2007 2008 this reduction in
cost of sequencing
really accelerated
and far outpaced even moore's law
which is is very um impressive because
we know how how much
computing power and the cost of
computing has dropped
over the course of the last 40 or 50
years well cost of sequencing was even
dropping at a much more rapid pace
until about nowadays in the last two
three years you can sequence a megabase
of dna which is a million base pairs
for about a cent
this is all on a log scale by the way
so this reduction in the cost of
sequencing has obviously opened up the
possibility of people being able to
afford to use sequencing to tackle many
problems that couldn't have been tackled
even say 10 years ago
so metagenomics is
essentially extending the concept of
genomics which focuses on a single
organism to
look at all of the organisms that live
in a community
organisms that live in communities and
interact if you want to study those
communities you need to look across all
the genomes of the organisms living in
it
and that is by definition what
metagenomics does
it's the study of metagenomes or genetic
material that is sampled directly from a
given environment
and this allows us to study communities
of organisms directly in their natural
environment you just sample the dna that
you find regardless of what organism it
comes from
and you sequence it and this bypasses
the need for isolating particular
organisms that you want to study and
cultivating them in the lab because
we found that a lot of the organisms
that we find in the environment in the
natural environment are fairly resistant
to cultivation in the lab
so the the primary tool that we have
used and have used in the past to study
these metagenomes is what's called 16s
ribosomal rna
this is a gene
and the schematic on this slide is the
uh 16s ribosomal rna gene
from an organism called thermos
thermophilus and essentially
the important thing about this gene
is that it's a high it's got some highly
conserved areas this gene is essential
for life and so there are various parts
of this gene
where the dna sequence is nearly
identical across
all bacteria
and that allows for so-called universal
pcr primers to be designed to those
highly conserved regions such that you
can take dna
taken from an environment which may have
come from all kinds of different
bacteria
and you can amplify
just this one gene
from those bacterial species
this gene is also important because in
between these highly conserved regions
are what are called hypervariable
regions and these are regions that are
less conserved and they have more
species specific
variation and so the signatures or the
dna sequence that's found in between
these highly conserved areas that falls
in these hyper variable regions
allows for you to then go back and match
against the database
and figure out which bacterium
each of your 16s ribosomal rna molecules
that you've sequenced have come from
so this method
i like to call it a bacterial census
because all it does is it goes in
takes material from a community
amplifies it and just tries to answer
the question which bacteria are there
and
who are they what type of bacteria and
in what abundance
and so if you if you look at the 16s
ribosomal rna and you stretch it out
it's about 1500 base pairs or more long
and if you look at the variability of it
in 50 base pair windows
this is what you get so the y-axis is
higher is increasing variability
and so you have all these areas that are
low variability
but they're interspersed with these high
variability areas and the high
variability or hypervariable regions
have been named v1 v2 v3 v4 v5 all the
way up through v9
and they correspond to these peaks and
so what we'll do in order to perform
such a bacterial census we will design a
primer let's say in this area which is
highly conserved
and another primer in this area
and then we will pcr amplify
the entire amplicon in between which
includes the v3 hypervariable region and
then we'll sequence it and use the
sequence of the v3 hypervariable region
to match back to a 16s database to
figure out
which bacteria were there and in what
quantities
now
there's another more powerful technique
but also more expensive which is called
shotgun metagenomics and this is often
what people mean when they say
metagenomics even though technically
metagenomics refers to the concept of
studying these microbial communities
but what shotgun metagenomics is is it's
you take the same type of sample you
just take all the dna you find in an
environment
but instead of
amplifying up just this one gene from
all the bacterial organisms
you actually sequence all the dna
and when you sequence all the dna you're
going to get dna from the host organism
if you were sampling from say the
surface of the skin
or
if you're sampling in an environmental
area like in the soil you may get dna
from animals that live there but also
you're going to get dna from the
bacteria that's there
fungi
viruses everything and then you just
shotgun it up which means
basically mechanically fragmented to
small pieces
that can be sequenced and then you take
a look
at what was there and this has the
advantage that it's it's fair it's
unbiased compared to 16s
because 16s you have the pcr step which
can bias what you find
whereas shotgun metagenomics you're just
sequencing everything and you're not pcr
amplifying it beforehand
now
that has its pluses and minuses one of
the minuses of that is that if you are
taking a sample from a host let's say
you're taking a
a sample from the surface of the skin
you're going to get a lot of dna that is
host
and you're also going to get some
bacteria you're going to get some fungi
viruses and so on well if you're
primarily interested in the the
microbial organisms
much of your sequencing effort is
actually going to go towards the host
it can be up depending on what type of
sample you have it can be up to 90 plus
percent
of your sequencing might be human let's
say if you're taking a microbial sample
from a human
but
so you may have to do a lot more
sequencing in order to answer the
question that you want to answer but if
you think back to that cost of
sequencing dropping as much as has
that allows you to do
a lot more sequencing for
less cost
so but one of the things that i want to
highlight is is and we're we're looking
at this in terms of a project where
we've done both 16s
ribosomal rna sequencing
and we've also done shotgun metagenomics
on the same samples
and one thing that you
get is when you
match the 16s ribosomal rna back to
databases
often you can only unambiguously
determine
the genus of the organisms that are
present
you don't get down to the species level
very often often you get stuck at the
genus level and that's just because the
16s sequence
may be equally close to
many different species of the same genus
but with shotgun metagenomics if you're
primarily interested in the taxonomic
composition the majority of your reeds
you can get to species level or even
potentially beyond to strain level
so that is a major advantage of using
shotgun metagenomics
and so i'll just show you an example
this is um one of the subjects that we
did 16s ribosomal rna sequencing on and
this is a this is a study of
women and it's it's looking at their
vaginal microbiome
and some of the women
come down with a dysbiotic condition
which is called bacterial vaginosis and
this is a condition where
as i said before the normally dominating
species of organisms in the environment
start to become less prevalent
and other opportunistic organisms come
in and start to take over
and so what this this heat map is
showing is actually it's a time course
and these are days of the study so this
time course where we started sequencing
was day 36 for this particular subject
and we went all the way through day 66
and on the x-axis are the different
organisms that we found
and
we tried to classify as far down as we
could we could get to species level in
many cases
but also lots of times we're only left
at like say the genus level
but what you can see from this
particular subject
is that
originally
her vaginal microbiome is dominated by a
couple of species of lactobacillus so
this one lactobacillus crespatus
and this other one lactobacillus
gaseride
are primarily the dominant organisms
there's a number of other things here
but up through about day 49 this is what
dominates
then we have some metadata up here and
you can see that on day 50
this subject
reports that mensie starts
well when mensie starts
she starts to lose the dominance of
almost immediately really she loses the
dominance of lactobacillus chrospatus
and gensoni
and a number of other organisms start to
come in
and proliferate
and then
continuing along she reports
sexual activity
on day 56 after which suddenly
her lactobacillus is completely gone
and now the dominant organisms are
gardnerella vaginalis which is a
bacteria that's been implicated in
bacterial vaginosis
along with uh
prevotel obivia
and adipobian vaginae and a few other
organisms anaerococcus tetradius
and so she ends up at this point
in a state of having bv and this is
something that we measure with what's
called a nugent score and as long as the
nugent score is three or below
we say she has a normal microbiota
but once it rises to four to six we'll
say
that the woman has an intermediate
microbiome and if she gets to a seven or
above she's diagnosed with bv and so you
can see that she jumps
from this normal
microbiota to suddenly a bv microbiota
which persists for several days
but then once mensi ceases
she
goes back to a lactobacillus dominant
microbiota so essentially her
normally dominating chrospatus and
jensenite come back
and once again dominate her community
so the interesting thing here is that
for this same subject
we chose a subset of samples
leading up
to
her diagnosis of bv
and we did shotgun sequencing on them so
due to cost considerations we didn't do
every day we did every other day so we
did day 47 49 51 53 55
and then day 57 which was the day she
was diagnosed with bv
and when we look at that
using shotgun methods
we find very similar results
now one of the drawbacks that you can
have with shotgun
sequencing for metagenomics is that
the matching to the databases might not
be as is it can be more precise but
there are a lot more blind spots because
not all of the bacteria
have had their whole genome sequenced
whereas the 16s ribosomal rna sequences
have been studied
very thoroughly and often will be
available for you to match against
but what you see is very similar to what
we saw with the 16s is that
you know initially she's dominated by
this lactobacillus cresponus and
lactobacillus gastrin
and then
you also see here that she has another
species of lactobacillus which didn't
pop up in the 16s lactobacillus
vaginalis and that's just because it
it's close enough to the other organisms
that it's not
able to be discerned from those other
organisms by 16s but you can by shotgun
and then what you see is that the
gardnerella vaginalis starts to dominate
here
and also privitel obivia
and
a few other organisms but notice here
that the granularity of detail is finer
you can actually see that
the gardiner ella vaginalis was there at
low levels
even when she was dominated by
lactobacilli
when you look back at these graphs
you can also see that it was there at
fairly low levels leading up
but you can see a progressive ramp up
here of adipobian vaginae which really
dominates
on the day of bv but you can see it it
ramps up here
you can also see a ramping up but at a
quicker rate of prevotel obivia
so these are sort of just an example to
show you the types of things that you
can see with shotgun sequencing compared
to what you can see with 16s and we
actually did this on three other
subjects
which i don't have time to show you the
data for
but
this method allows us to not only look
at
the bacterial communities but we also
were able to find
that there's a little bit of fungal
candida albicans that shows up in one of
our subjects and then there's also some
viral sequences so
alpha papillomavirus is present in
subject k-12
and human herpes virus 4 is present in
subject k20 and these are things that
you don't find with 16s ribosomal rna
sequencing
so with the shotgun sequencing we could
actually go in and
look at you know not only
sorry
okay i think somebody's off of mute that
doesn't mean to be off of mute
so
when we look at all the data that we got
from our shotgun metagenomics as i said
the majority of the sequence was human
actually
84.62 of our sequencing data mapped to
human
whereas only 12.4 percent
mapped to bacteria and 2.92 percent
mapped to other microbial organisms
and then if you zoom in on the other
microbial organisms
71 percent of that sequence was fungal
27 protozoan a little over a percent are
keel and then very little of it about
less than one percent was viral
if we zoom in on that viral sequence
you can see a variety of different
viruses we found we found alpha
papilloma virus
uh human gamma herpes virus those are
the things that showed up on those heat
maps i showed you we found some other
viral sequences as well
and then one of the things that we're
really interested in is bacteriophage so
subset of the viral sequences was
bacteriophage
and we found a few lactobacillus phages
that's the majority of what we found and
we found a number of other phages so
this just gives you an idea of all the
different things that you can see
when you when you pay
for the additional uh cost of doing
shotgun metagenomic sequencing
and i'd imagine
you know that the
the thing that's popping into your head
right now or at least should be is uh
what is the cost differential well
basically for us
i'm one of the founding members of our
micro
of our metagenomics resources at lsu
health sciences we have a group that's
called
the microbial genomics resource group
and we we perform these kinds of assays
for people around the world
primarily we work with people
in our general area but we've done
sequencing of samples for places as far
as puerto rico and even some places in
europe
and
our cost it cost us about 40 to 45
dollars to process a single sample
for 16s so that includes
dna isolation
uh amplicon preparation
and
indexing and sequencing so that's all
the molecular aspects of it
whereas if we're doing shotgun
sequencing
it's going to cost us
at least 200 per sample and that is
entirely dependent upon how much depth
of sequencing
is needed so if you need more depth you
want really deep shotgun metagenomics
we may it may cost us 300 maybe 400
dollars
a shallow shotgun
could be 200. and it's partly dependent
upon what sequencing platforms we have
available
but i i have a um
a web server
which i i host
and if you you know
run over to that web page
please try again later if you continue
to have issues please contact support
that's alexa
all right so if you run over to
metagenomics this website
what you're going to find is
various links so i have some recorded
lectures on informatics
i have a link to my lab page and then i
have a link to the microbial genomics
resource group
and the microbial genomics resource
group if you you know visit that webpage
we have
a bunch of information there about what
we do who we are
former members of the group
a variety of news items and then
importantly probably the most useful
um you know after you get through all
the publications is this cost and sample
submission which
lists out all of the different services
that we have available and the prices
for each and then we have some sample
submission guidelines
but i just wanted to you know highlight
that
that that resource is available and we
work with people all around the world
as i also mentioned there on that same
website the lectures button
takes you to a series of lectures that i
conducted several years ago that have
been recorded
and are available via streaming um these
recorded lectures persist and are
available for viewing on demand i did a
lecture series in general on an
introduction to informatics and then
another one that was an introduction to
microbial communities
i also as was mentioned i i
helped co-organize an annual conference
on
bioinformatics and computational biology
we just run last year our eighth annual
conference on computational biology and
bioinformatics that was last april
um the link is here
and i'll provide these slides for for
distribution by pine biotech
um
and we had a whole session in the last
conference that was on the nih strides
initiative and this is an initiative
that nih has kicked off to
help with the transition to cloud
computing and we had a keynote talk
from amazon web services which is one of
the providers in nih strides and another
keynote from
the google cloud research group which is
another provider of
nih strides compute
we had other imminent bioinformatics and
computational biology speakers
and these topics that they covered
included the covid19 pandemic modeling
gut microbiome
herpes virus and the role of statistics
and epigenetics research and so here was
the flyer from
our conference from 2021 all the
speakers that we had and we're very soon
going to start uh organization of the
coming 2022 conference
and likely that'll be virtual due to the
ongoing pandemic it was virtual last
year and the 2020 conference actually
had to be cancelled because we didn't
have time to pivot to a virtual format
so my research lab just to give you an
idea at lsu
one of the uh sort of tenants of the lab
when i built it is that i wanted to be
an open uh environment so i didn't put
up partitions or cubicles or anything
like that
because i wanted to promote uh the
collaboration between all of the
students and and post-docs and
researchers that work in my lab
and that's served very well um
essentially people sit around the
perimeter work at their workstations but
if they run into an issue they can just
turn around to their neighbor and um you
know ask and see if they if they have
enough
an opinion on how to resolve the issue
so i've had several people who worked in
the lab and have uh rotated through it
and ongoing research projects uh most of
my research has shifted to be in the
vaginal microbiota and its interaction
with stis
i have a
major study on uh chlamydia
trachmatis that virus and
essentially how
the microbiome interacts with natural
clearance of the infection
i have another uh big project that's
that's running in south africa right now
on uh adverse birth outcomes
um in that interaction with microbiota
and then i have my
primary focus on bacterial vaginosis
i have a couple grants working on that
and then we just got a new grant awarded
where we're going to look at
bacterial vaginosis and testosterone use
in transgender men and we're just about
to undergo
uh start enrollment for that study and
most of this work is actually with my my
primary collaborator christina musney
who's at you university of alabama
birmingham
i'm also a member of the center for
clinical and translational research at
the university of alabama birmingham and
i'm a member of the louisiana biomedical
research network here that is
flagshipped by the lsu campus in baton
rouge but extends throughout louisiana
as was mentioned early on i recently got
an nsf grant which we've used to
establish a high performance computing
cluster at the school of medicine and
the lsu health sciences center here in
new orleans
it's a tiger fish cluster here's a
picture i took soon after it was
deployed
it's got
1440 total compute cores and a
193.6 teraflops
36 compute nodes each of that which
has 192 gigabytes of ram it has
a very uh large ram memory node which
has 1.5 terabytes of ram and it's got a
gpu node as well
so it it serves a variety of purposes
for us and it allows us to perform some
of the
very compute intensive shotgun
metagenomics analysis that we need to do
lastly uh their lsu health sciences this
has been in progress for a while
my colleague here cendo hicks in the
genetics department has spearheaded a
bioinformatics track
within a master's program in biomedical
sciences and
we had intended to start enrollment of
that program
a few years ago but the covid 19
pandemic intervened
and we now have pushed the plan start of
the program to next fall
with an application deadline in april
but you know again the start of this
program is really dependent on
our evolving covid restrictions and
results of applicants to the program
whether we get that started or not
but the program its purpose will be to
integrate
instruction in computer programming
bioinformatics and computational biology
along with the myriad applications to
biomedical research that we do at the
lsu health sciences center
and
with that hopefully
i'm somewhat on time
and i will
have an opportunity to take some
questions
thank you so much dr taylor it was a
really enlightening session for all of
us we got to know about a lot of
things about metagenomics a lot of
research applications
and
various challenges and the ways to
address them as well
thank you so much for
your time and your presentation we do
have a few questions from our
participants which i will be taking up
one by one and
you can address them
so
here's the first question that was asked
by our
audience
he says was the patient of your study
was under some other medications because
during her mises
minses her biomass of lactobacillus had
almost disappeared but in the same
period she had other
dominant bacterium
colonies is this linked with the
physical presence of bacteria in the
body or was the lactobacillus phages
that you showed later responsible for
this depletion
so i will say uh not that we know of so
she so this was a prospective study
and women were enrolled in the study
and followed for 90 days and a an
exclusion criteria for enrollment in the
study was
having an sti or other or being on any
kind of antibiotics within the past 14
days and so everyone who is enrolled in
the study was healthy and and not on
other medications at the time
but this is a fairly high risk
population and so it's possible
that
due to you know sexual activity or other
other things that she may have
gotten an sti during the study um
because they weren't being tested
throughout the study for that
essentially the samples were collected
for up to 90 days
and then when the samples were processed
if a woman was found to have bacterial
vaginosis she was called in
to get treatment
but the samples that we would have
worked on would have all been before
that so all of the data that i showed
you
would have been without any kind of
you know antibiotic treatment or other
drug treatment
uh being administered
prior to when those samples were taken
or sequenced so we do think that the
phage might have a role and that's
actually something that we're working on
right now that's why i'm so interested
in the results um that we're that we're
working on we've got a manuscript that's
uh that's about to go in for review
all right so
let's expand from that point as where
you said that depletion of microbes due
to antibiotics and the administration of
probiotics so
we know that probiotics are not really
verified by the fda but in your opinion
how effective they are and what are the
ways in which probiotics are being
improved through modern research
so i'm very much at this point in time
a probiotic skeptic if you will
i think a lot of the market for
probiotics is a little bit of snake oil
because we don't
as a scientific community
know enough to really play god in the
sense that
when you have various conditions or
dysbiosis
we don't know exactly what needs to be
put back to fix that and that's the best
evidence of that is
c diff infections
um people have tried you know the the
standard attempts at
resetting a c diff infection is
antibiotics and often
it kills a bunch of organisms and makes
the condition worse well you try
probiotics you try all kinds of things
the thing that's been successful
is fecal microbiota transplant so take
fecal material a healthy bacterial
community from a healthy donor
and transplant it into someone suffering
from c diff and that's had almost 90
percent effectiveness rate and the
reason is well you put that healthy
bacteria back well if we knew exactly
what needed to be added we could get
around the idea of having to take fecal
material and implant it
but
we don't really understand at that at
that level yet
what needs to be put back so you know
our probiotics good they probably are
but
you really need to know which probiotics
and what they're going to do
at this time they're not regulated by
the fda they're considered like
nutritional supplements
you know so
it's it's hard to really know what
you're taking and
what the results are going to be
all right thank you so much for the
answer here's another question from our
audience
he asked did you perform an in-silico
pcr test or some sort of evaluation to
really get an insight on the primary
coverage for the 16s databases before
choosing the primer set and can you
please share your thoughts on how in
silico tests can be done to get maximum
coverage for amplicon sequencing
so
what i'll point you to because it's a
very involved answer is we actually did
publish a paper several years ago
which was an in silico analysis of
several different primer sets
and you know my name is very common so
if you look for christopher taylor
you're going to find people all over the
the gamut
but um you know a more uncommon name
that was my co-author on this paper
was elliot lefkowitz and if you if you
search for him you'll you'll be able to
find the paper it's it it's got in
silico in its title
and we did a whole analysis on the best
primer sets and we ended up
what we use in our microbial genomics
resource group is we we study the v4
region
and part of that's due to the
limitations of the sequencing technology
we're using in in terms of how long of a
region we can study more
more length if you can cover more hyper
variable regions is better
and in particular uh pacific biosciences
has
the you know they have a platform where
you can you can basically sequence the
whole 16s molecule and you can get down
to species level most of the time and
they're really pushing that technology
now we just we don't have that
sequencing technology in our lab
all right definitely
it's a good idea to check out all the
resources and the papers that you've
published and
kind of continuing from that particular
point there's a question in the chat
and it is about sharing the link
to your platform that you had mentioned
and your website
and
he just wants to confirm it is it
metagenomics.lsu
hsc.com or not so it would be good
yeah let me type it in metagenomics
that should get you there
all right well that's great thank you so
much for sharing and
here's the last question that i have for
you so you mentioned the various
sequencing categories and types and
their different pros and cons and their
challenges and
what according to you would be some of
the computational challenges that one
might face while doing metagenomics
research and what's a good way to
address them
well so computational challenges um
16s ribosomal rna sequencing and
characterization that analysis is fairly
well worked out
there are really good tools that you can
use for that and the
the analyses aren't super duper compute
intensive you can often do them on a
desktop workstation sometimes even a
powerful laptop like a macbook pro
but once you get the shotgun metagenomic
sequencing you're dealing with a lot
more data
and there are tools available to process
the data but if you want to do something
fairly
compute intensive like de novo assembly
of your sequencing reads you really need
access to a high performance computing
cluster like tiger fish and that's one
of the you know main applications that
we pushed in our
in our grant application to get that
platform was that you know we need this
sort of resource to be able to
do shotgun metagenomics analysis at
scale
all right well thank you so much for
your answers dr taylor and here's
another request in the chat to kindly
share the link through which
our participants can apply for the ems
program at lsu that you were talking
about
right i will
see if i can copy it
and
paste it into the chat
so that link should get you to um the
page about the program itself and then
there's information on that page
that allows for
you to find out where to go to apply
right and there's someone who also wants
to ask about this ms bioinformatics
program that is it and remotely taught
program because due to the travel
restrictions for covent
and
the person being an international
student can he travel to louisiana right
now or
there's a method for distant learning as
well
so um
that's to be determined at this point uh
cendo and i have had discussions about
that i like the idea of having
a um you know virtual option
uh
kendo himself is actually from
africa and so he has an association with
several universities in africa and his
idea behind the program was that we
would have sort of
this crossing of
we bring a lot of students here to the
us
from south african universities
and uh of course covet kind of got in
the way of all that and so everything is
still
evolving right now we've had a
a
a number of new
leadership in our graduate school who
may be more
open to the idea of virtual programs so
we're trying to push that but for right
now
what i was discussing with the fall
um
the plans for that if we were able to go
forward with it would be to start that
program up as an actual
normal in-person
um master's program where you have a
residency here
uh where you're
here for the education but in the future
hopefully we'll be able to come to some
kind of a balance
well all right thank you so much dr
taylor for your time it was
wonderful to have you with us and
your talk was full of insights full of
information and it was a pleasure to
learn from you and also talk to you
thank you so much for your time oh i see
one more one more question about the
tiger fish cluster how much did it cost
to set up um
the grant that we got from nsf was a 400
000 grant and i think it cost us about
360 000
was spent on
the cluster itself and then the other
was on student workers and various other
things to get everything going
yeah that's a really cost incent
intensive investment but definitely it
helps a lot of analysis and the
computational power it brings to the
research lab is tremendous
so thank you so much dr taylor for your
time and it was great to know
a lot of things about lsu
hsc and your research for my dear
audience
any questions that you might have
regarding the msc program in lsu you can
definitely
check out the page shared by dr taylor
and you can also email the persons
involved in the research programs and
admissions centers so that way you can
definitely
learn more about
the program and also
get answer to all your questions
so
moving on with
the last bit of today's webinar that i
have for you and since i i see that all
of you are pretty much interested about
this exciting domain of comics that is
known as metagenomics and
you are also excited just like me i
would like to introduce you to the
omixlogic training course on
metagenomics and it's a very in-depth
learning experience a program developed
in association with dr trailer and other
organizations that find biotech the
omics logic training is an integration
of interactive sessions both live and
asynchronous self-guided study materials
and practical assignments on the t bio
info platform the t bio info platform is
an ai enabled cloud-based analysis
platform
where people like you and me who are
more biologists then coders would not
have to worry about the problems or
the difficulties that we might have to
face with coding so here with the point
and click interface of the tbi info
platform you can do your analysis very
easily and very quickly and all of this
is
taught in these programs and these
self-guided study materials
in the omixlogic meta genomics program
you get to learn about omix technologies
in microgram studies both
from the perspective of a sequencing
based approach and also in from the
perspective of mass tech based approach
you also get to learn about microbiome
functions
differentiation of the immune system and
food digestion and nutrition and all the
way to its
function in the prevention of pathogens
invasion and as i was telling you the
hands-on practical aspect you also get
to learn about amplicon data sequencing
through the data to pipeline which is
embedded in the t bio info server and
you get to learn the data analysis by
actually performing on a real data set
taken from a publicly available data
talking about publicly available data
you will definitely get insights into
the databases where you can find such
data for your projects and analysis to
get started with
so databases like green genes silva ncbi
rdp are some great resources for your
metagenomics
projects
and the idea of
doing all of these hands-on learning is
to actually push you or get yourself
ready for a research fellowship or a
research project where you can get
enrolled for
an internship somewhere or get started
with your own project and complete it
and apply all the knowledge the
techniques the skills that you learn as
a part of these omics logic training
courses
talking about fellowship here's an
example of
a research project completed by one of
our research fellows whose name is miss
vedic from amateur university noida and
her work deals with the transcriptomics
of kovite 19.
talking about covet 19 very soon in the
month of february we will be launching
a dedicated program where we will be
talking about bioinformatics for
infectious diseases taking the health
and the datasets from kovid19 and other
infectious diseases such as malaria and
ebola and understand its
origin its pathogenesis and also push
forward towards developing
possible therapeutics for these
infectious diseases
talking about other specialized courses
that are offered by omixologic platform
there's precision oncology
and introductory course to
bioinformatics which gives you the idea
of what biology and informatics
integration looks like and really helps
you understand the logic behind omics
there's a dedicated
program on omixology genomics and
genomics in the virtual lab where you
get to work hands-on again and develop
more skills in genomics using python and
our coding languages
we also provide our mixologic
transcriptomics
data science for biomedical data sets
and other programs which gives you a
holistic experience and skill set to get
started with your bio informatics
project and to get started with your
scientist career
now here's an announcement which i would
like to mention about our partnerships
with louisiana state university and as a
result of this partnership we are
bringing several free courses for the
students of lsu to
get enrolled and to get experienced in
various courses such as mathematics
transcriptomics genomics and
metagenomics
another great
collaboration that we have recently
established is with nepi which stands
for national association of idea
principle investigators which covers 23
states in the united states of america
and puerto rico as a result of this
collaboration find biotech would also
provide free training to the students
who are associated with the nepa network
and this is a great opportunity for you
to leverage the resources provided by
fine biotech
talking about our international
collaborations recently we signed a
massive mou between amateur university
and panbiotic which resulted in forming
a great collaborative partnership
between amity university noida campus
and the real focus of this partnership
is to bring industry and academic
internships for students in india and
elsewhere where students can get the
flavor of the applications of
bioinformatics in industry as well as
lab-based academic research
talking about collaborations there was
another great collaboration established
between pine biotech and faba which
stands for the federation of
asian bioinformatics associations so
this is a huge network of the giants in
biotechnology and bioinformatics in the
entire asian continent and as a result
of this part partnership and
collaboration we will be also able to
bring various exciting opportunities for
the students who are based and located
in asia and
in the days to come you will definitely
get more news of various events that we
will be launching in association with
fava
so having said that it's a good a good
idea for all of you to get
in touch with us so that you'd never
miss anything that we have to share
so
we are present on each and every social
media platform that you are so feel free
to get in touch with us and
follow us in any of the social media
handles that you are present in and in
that way you can stay in touch with us
get to know about
any of our events that is coming up
starting from internships to fellowships
to any other webinar such as this one
so as a part of psionics we organize
these sort of
guest speaker webinars every month
twice every month
in the month of november we had a
session on bioinformatics and data
science in december we focused on study
abroad strategies and tactics how to how
to get a scholarship for studying abroad
and
things like that in january we are
covering metal genomics
and very
soon we will be having the month of
february where we will be having
dedicated webinars in the domain of
bioinformatics and data science
and in march we will be having a big
conference which is known as omics logic
research symposium where you will have
many great scientists and
experts in the industry
domain come together to share their
insights as well as students will get an
opportunity to participate in
the poster
poster conference
competition so again
do stay in touch with us through our
social media because we will be sharing
the call for abstracts for the poster
session very soon and we are looking
forward to your submissions
for the omnilogic research symposium
now finally i would like to inform you
about our next psionic session that is
going to be
held on the 4th of february at 5 pm in
the standard time you will be receiving
emails for the same and this session
will be taken by dr abhishek sengupta
who is an assistant professor at the
center for computational biology and
bioinformatics at amity institute of
biotechnology i am at the university of
the pradesh and he will be talking about
network construction and inference as an
elegant approach to understand disease
pathogenesis so once again it would be
great to have you all with us on board
for this exciting webinar
which will be done by dr abhishek
finally your opinion matters a lot to us
so we would definitely love to hear from
you what you feel about our
webinars what things you like and what
are the areas where you think we can
improve so definitely fill out this
feedback form
your opinions will only help us get
better from this point of time
having said that
that's
that brings us to the end of today's
webinar
i enjoyed it a lot i had
so many exciting moments from this
particular webinar it was amazing to see
all of you present today
do
follow us and join all our social media
groups so that we can communicate with
one another and help each other and
stand by one stand by one another's
journey which is really the goal of
cyanics bioinformatics student club
so
that's it for
me because
that's all i have for you guys today if
you have any question feel free to
write down in the chat section i will
definitely
help you out with anything that you need
and
i can see that
you need the link for the research
symposium
so i will definitely
share it with you and
i have also copied your email and i will
make sure that our team reaches out to
you very soon
so
guys that brings us to the end of
today's
psionic session if you have any
questions
feel free to put it down in the chat if
not that
goodbye from all of us today i really
had an amazing time with all of you once
again thank you so much dr chris taylor
for joining us today and
for your time it was a privilege for all
of us to have you as our guest speaker
today
thank you everyone and wish you all the
best in life see you very soon on
the
4th of february 2022
all right everyone then good night and
have a great day ahead see you bye
you